les sourires et le soulagement sur les
visages de ces bosnien avec retard la
bosnie herzégovine a reçu le mois
dernier ses premiers lots de vaccins par
le biais du programme
kovacs
je suis bien sûr furieux et déçu que
nous soyons les derniers en europe étant
donné que nous sommes et avons toujours
été un pays européen
nous devrions être parmi les premiers à
recevoir le vaccin
maintenant que nous en sommes arrivés là
la campagne de vaccination a commencé
ici aujourd'hui elle se passe très bien
il n'y a pas de foules exigences des
pays donateurs problèmes de transports
dans les villes et les villages reculés
règles juridiques et administratives
complexes
le programme kovacs fête son premier
anniversaire dans la douleur kovacs un
mécanisme co dirigé aujourd'hui par l'
oms
l'alliance du vaccin et la coalition
pour les innovations en matière de
préparation aux épidémies selon le
directeur de l'om est ce le moment est
venu d'écrire une nouvelle histoire
alors que 142 pays défavorisés sont
concernés sur les plus de 18 milliards
d'euros de budget prévu cette année 15
milliards manquent encore à l'appel
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
comparé aux milliers de milliards de
dollars que les gouvernements dépensent
pour soutenir leurs économies et aux
revenus massif que la plupart des
fabricants de vaccins génère une pique
adressée aux dirigeants des pays les
plus riches mais aussi aux géants de la
pharmacie car la solidarité prônée par
le programme kovacs laisse encore à
désirer
au niveau global près de 900 millions de
doses de vaccin ont été administrées
mais 80% d'entre elles ont filé vers les
pays les plus riches tandis que les pays
les plus pauvres ont dû se partager 0,3
pour cent d'entre elles cette semaine et
dans le cadre de kovacs la france a
annoncé la livraison de cinq cent mille
doses aux pays les plus pauvres d'ici à
la mi juin
un cent mille sont déjà en partance pour
des pays africains et des doses du
vaccin
astrazeneca
[Applaudissements]